you're going to see more and more
narratives about
racial hatred on camp on campus
especially
even if the left has to contrive the
metapod cloth great example of this
last week students of color what color i
don't know
at white bear lake high school south
campus in minnesota
were invited into a group chat on
instagram where they were sent
threatening and racist messages oh man
this is a big deal
these you know classic white
supremacists
in high schools are going in threatening
these students
and this is going to be a big
school-wide issue and then oh wait a
second nope never mind
never mind it's okay no big deal nothing
to see here let's move on why
because it appears to have been a hoax
i could have told you i i couldn't have
told you with 100 certainty that this
was a hoax
but i would have i would have bet a lot
of money that it was a hoax
i actually detail a countless examples
of this
in my upcoming book speechless available
now for pre-order which is
that on issues of race on issues of sex
you hear again and again and again the
racist there was a
burning cross there was a swastika
painted there was the n-word painted all
over
people's dorms oh it was a hoax oh it
was fake oh
they made it up themselves the same
thing is true of the
the alleged campus rape epidemic time
and time and time again
how many high-profile examples do we
need going back to the duke lacrosse
case
of hoaxes here why why are there hoaxes
because they know
the left knows that the narrative is
extraordinarily valuable and victimhood
carries social currency so if you create
incentives for that sort of thing
you're going to get a whole lot more of
it
that's that's the way the business works
that's the way grievance incorporated
works
and if you create incentives in the
other direction towards say
virtue humility resignation
courage all of these virtues prudence
then you will get more of that as well
why are these students
creating the hoaxes it's not even just
the student's fault it's not that
they're
total fraudsters i mean they are they
are fraudsters but it's not that this
came out of nowhere it's because that is
how they're being educated that is the
indoctrination that they're
they're getting in school from a very
young age it's what they're being taught
the santa clara county office of
education
just uh gave a presentation to educators
that had to have these struggle sessions
how to indoctrinate children
in this ridiculous racial ideology uh
the the presenter here was a guy named
jorge pacheco
and this comes to us via chris ruffo at
city journal
this is what the presenter told the
teachers quote we have to be
extra careful about what is being said
since we can't just say something
controversial now that we're in people's
homes
parents can take out of context or see
what materials are being used
so we need to be careful of what they
see
the kids become a subject and you are
intending to awaken them to the
oppression
that they aren't aware of but that they
are actively participating in
then how to lead to social change wow
this is
out of a cartoon that this guy would say
this one
our education is so radical that you
have to hide it from parents
the implication here parents should have
absolutely no say in how their children
are raised
only we the radicals who have taken over
the
instruments of the state only we should
have a say in that and three
false consciousness this is an idea that
was developed
by the neo-marxists after
it comes from the idea of marx that that
basically you have to awaken the
proletariat
the working classes the oppressed masses
to their own oppression
uh because the turns out that the
working classes tended to have some
common sense and they didn't go for the
radicals crazy theories
so then beginning with people like
antonio gramsci
the italian marxist philosopher and
communist politician the frankfurt
school
later on the new left which was led by
one of the chief figures from the
frankfurt school
you see this idea really flowering
during the second wave of feminism in
the 1970s
when people would have struggle sessions
no different than the kind of
indoctrination people are getting their
workplaces or in their schools right now
where i kid you not
women especially would go into these
struggle sessions they'd feel happy
they'd love their family
they you know maybe they'd bring a
little uh tupperware of
some delicious treat they made right
they go they go into the struggle
session
and they leave extremely irritated and
angry and resentful
because they had been made aware of
their own oppression there's a very
famous
essay i also detail this in my book
there's a very famous essay
called called the personal is political
by carol hanish this is credited with
really epitomizing the second wave of
feminism
where they celebrate this where these
women celebrate going to the wine and
cheese soirees w-h-i-n-e
and they would go and they'd say oh i'm
so glad that i'm
angry now i used i was so happy before
this and i loved my family but i'm so
glad now
that you radical feminists have given me
this resentment made me aware of my
oppression
that is exactly the same thing that this
presenter and the santa clara county
office of education is doing they're
saying we need to awaken
children to their own resentments if
they're not
resentful already we need to instill
resentment in them
only that way can we have revolution
hey hey hey before you go i need you to
smash
that subscribe button hit it ring the
bell
you know sometimes youtube doesn't
always want to recommend these videos
and people's feeds
so make sure you do that and you will
not miss another video